hey everybody the thor ragnarok reviews
are in and many are calling it not just
the best Thor movie but the best MCU
movie ever yes I know so much Chris
Hemsworth without even speaking lame
American everyone so guys we're gonna
break down all the deeper reasons why
thor ragnarok could be at Marvel's best
but also along with all the details you
need to know about what Punisher Justice
League han solo movie Walking Dead Game
of Thrones and more all best on the
requests that you got all based on the
requests that you guys sent us be a star
- what is start as well you should check
out our star download link in the
description below and you can upload
your reactions to your favorite movies
and TV shows and get them featured on
this show
upbeat kids speaking of real quick what
is the show quick reminder this is our
second week so that means it's a real
thing we did it it's called the need to
know it's our new rock stars deep dive
into all of the biggest stories of the
week the things that you guys absolutely
need to know if you're gonna call
yourself a nerd with cred and we're
trying to sneak in a little bit of an
extra thing with as many stores as we
can so that you can bring up a point at
a party and be like you know what you
don't know about that is this thing that
I'm stealing from the internet and what
our party's well I need some red cred
redemption video it's sam basher year
best but who's sweating away too much
right now in an air-conditioned room
Sammy I'm Erik Bosse another host
sitting at this table well let's get
started with our top story that we led
with requested by Logan and many others
on Stardust let's take a look
thor ragnarok I am so excited Tiger
Woods he is directing he directed what
we do in the shadows hunt for the
wildering my favorite director and with
him on the project I think this is gonna
be a mazing movie maybe even the best
Marvel movie yet yeah we said project on
our show
if you guys send us stuff on Stardust
and then you tag us at new rock stars on
there but let's go ahead and address
what he brought up right yeah everyone
is raving about thor ragnarok which at
this moment last I checked has a 98% on
34 reviews one had to be the outlier
like well I'm gonna well like and many
like logan are suggesting yes it could
be the best film in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but rather than just debate
whether or not that's true we thought
we'd dig into some deeper points about
what makes thor ragnarok stand out from
the rest of the MCU pack and don't worry
we are going to get into any spoilers
there was a premiere that doesn't mean
that we don't know what happens around
it and what approach is taken because I
think we all are just like Logan was are
huge what et Ed's GT is the director
that they chose for this movie so I'm
gonna kind of like kick us off I think a
little bit of why this is definitely be
even being considered potentially the
best one but I read some reviews and
it's exactly what I was hoping for you
know everyone knows that Marvel takes
risks on kind of like lesser-known
directors because they can bully them
into making whatever they want well they
still try to but also there's the idea
that they are supposed to inject new
life that is like they're like oh we
want you to bring
so this guy is hilarious everything he's
done has been very funny what they do in
shadows 100 people if you loo they
reckon side of the Conchords he was a
college roommate so he's a director he
actually plays a role in the movie too
but here's my real point this guy is not
only hilarious and the set reports have
been like he is so freakin funny on set
and we've had such a great time on
attractive but because he brought that
energy to the character of Thor I think
he fixed the biggest problem that Thor
has had throughout the first two movies
Thor is the most unrelatable character I
think in the MCU he is this like pretty
spoiled rich like prince basically right
I mean God yeah exactly and his jokes
are always as the pit of the joke and as
a straight man but also it's like oh I
don't get humans and it's like come on
you're an Asgardian everyone is roughly
human or at least they need to feel
human because even Rocket Raccoon feels
human right Bradley Cooper makes us
connect with that so that's why I think
it's the fact that he brought in humor
made Thor more authentic made him more
relatable and that's what I think people
are attaching to and that's why I get so
frustrated with Star Wars when anyone
tries to do the same thing they're like
no you injected humor into our war it's
like just let it happen there's a recent
k2i so is the most relatable character
man that movies bad I'll tell saying is
that you disagreeing or fight you say
it's good story
oh I'll tear that thing apart but we're
on Marvel yes superiors franchise
because it likes to embrace its
silliness right like it it coming from
like Doctor Strange when it's like you
know what at first they were like no
it's you know magic but there's a
science back on it then you're like you
know what what if we do like a full acid
trip like seeing where he just flies
through the multiverse that's
guardians the galaxy yeah his dad's a
planet this is a mixed time sense right
a beautiful thing of the soundtrack in
the whole thing which gave it again a
youthful tone and a relatability
yeah the mixtape you kidding me yeah and
but that in that weird way that like the
so Joss Whedon is obviously very funny
but he didn't have the weird thing that
you're talking about where it is yeah
yeah no it's and I think the the more
you make these movies they're what
they're this is the fifteen sixteen
seven I think it's a seventeen he gets a
75th you've got you have to you wrote it
down but let your freak flag fly the
hardest that was time let your freak
flag fly and especially do that with
Jeff Goldblum and I don't know if you
guys have seen I don't know if we have
photos of this but he recently did a
photo shoot and like a cat's way yes
it's amazing Jeff Goldblum is a hero if
he dies my life ends like that's how I
was gonna work he's he's a he will never
die he will never die but no just adding
him into this movie and a demon that
makes you realize what what they're
trying to do now like they're they're
taking themselves a little less
seriously and having fun that's what
needs to happen at the end of the day
this is a superhero movie when you start
taking superheroes and super powers and
like the end of the world because aliens
are coming if you take that seriously we
have problems
it's going to only really be an
entertaining film it's not you're not
going to see Batman you're not gonna see
Hulk
yeah to have thought-provoking
conversation afterwards oh wow
that existential crisis no instead you
have a really really fun time and this
only really happens when they
acknowledge the ridiculous nature of
what they're doing poke fun at
themselves and then that sets a tone
where everyone can just relax and enjoy
it how you get a general audience kids
that's how it works but I think also the
thing you're describing can work for
certain movies the problem with the
thorah ones has been it's been like in
the middle yes are we gonna take this
really seriously but also I'm gonna call
out this or is kat dennings making fun
of the word d linear it's like yeah wow
you got a pic great joke solid joke well
and you know i think this is the first
movie to really use thor and whole
properly in my last week we spoke about
how the previous Hulk movie is kind of
flopped and that they weren't the best
execution of this particular character
and because of that and that happened a
little while ago now he's almost been
like the plague people haven't really
written him into it so well they've
taken a huge step back not in the comics
but definitely in the movies um he has
some how does the standalone movie since
being a part of this this Avengers and
then of course the last two Thor movies
weren't the best especially the second
one what the hell anyway madly Portman
can't save a movie like Star Wars or
Thor oh that's a bad movie but in this
particular one they have got two
characters that really do deserve their
own storyline but they're not confident
in it yet but I think that this time
they've done such a good job obtaining
them up together in no one else's shadow
so when you have the Avengers assembled
it's usually about Captain America and
Iron Man Iron Man I mean let's not even
get into Hawkeye and instead of playing
one part of a larger team they get to
you know Thor gets to be Thor exactly
purely and you know in terms of Natasha
yeah and Hawkeye being the humans of the
Avengers and having their kind of like
plotline we've got these two being the
strongest characters yeah and so I kind
of think that you can take it to a next
level knowing that these are the two
really really strong and powerful and
probably the biggest threat to each
other yeah in the movie so yeah I'm all
about the fact that these guys have
their own storyline really well executed
getting the spotlight that they deserve
but having fun with it and I've heard
more than once that people that have
seen this movie are now considering the
whole to be their favorite Avenger so
far but it's the Hulk I mean you have
everybody else and then somehow the line
is Falcon strokes from black
well what I'm loving about what this
movie looks like it's going to be is it
looks like a movie that like knows what
it is you know like I think part of the
brilliance of using the ragnerok concept
from the comics is it like it also
applies to what this film is on a meta
level like in the comics Ragnarok and in
North Mossad mythology it's this
apocalyptic event right that destroys
Asgard it's actually part of a cycle
like it happens over and over again it's
a rebirth that to rebirth and the
director said that he actually wanted to
use this idea when it came to his
approach like he wanting to embrace the
apocalypse to inspire him with his
approach nee I have a quote here he said
right you wanted to do with the Ragnarok
way full out heading for the fire
sprinting full speed toward Armageddon
and like compare this to what happens in
other like big scale Avengers events
it's always the end of the world or at
the end of the galaxy and it's some
doomsday event that has to be stopped
but I think that men and that's why it
was refreshing because the stakes was so
much smaller right pun intended but it
also kind of humanized the whole thing
right and imagine a version of ant-man
that didn't have like multiple directors
on it all trying to battle for what the
tone of the movie is going to be a great
idea like sometimes they make movies
where like like multiple directors
direct different scenes and you get a
little realizing that James Gunn and
both in their movies right so I'm just
looking forward to a movie that's
willing to go for broke and rather than
trying to stop the in the world it's
just gonna like enjoy the ship as it
goes down you know and just have a blast
alright I think that's what comic books
is hello man I thought this was the most
positive thing until that end there then
you know I mean it all burns down a
trilogy there's I unless this movie
likes to billion dollars I don't think
they'll make another tour movie I think
there
no come on imagine the end of Titanic
with the string quartet that's
everyone's favorite part imagine the
marketing wonder the four is written to
Thor so if you're if you're wondering
why things sound different about Thor
Ragnarok I think that's basically it the
creative approach behind it is
refreshing it he got full credit control
and he did the Ragnarok approach was
essentially I can't we're saying he's
gonna burn it all down
or like succeed wildly and it sounds
like he did by taking a huge risk yeah
I'm so excited I cannot wait that's
worth whoo two weeks away one week away
we're closed
everybody but damn wasn't show choir
I was anyways since last week we we
implemented a trivia question last week
the loser though has to drink the rest
of my water
[Music]
yeah it was a close is a close call and
I lost but that was crazy and I had a
drink Mott's bet and now I have the I
have the honor of asking this week's
trivia question oh you don't even know I
don't even know what it is
I thought you pulled that out of my
chest and you needed a key to unlock it
cool oh oh oh we're going into it all
right the question the trivia
questioning guys you can comment down
below see if you get this right see if
you beat us to it
but then don't cheat and write the
comment when you get to the end of the
video that's it
what is the Hulk Bruce banners mother's
name again what is the Hulk Bruce
banners mother's name sure question
it makes you write your name at the top
date it then sign it at the bottom
hmm okay now real quick the Hulk's mom
or Bruce banners mom Hulk like a hulked
out a woman where any uh like you know a
mom dress at all moms get when they come
moms okay and then we write how much we
wager all right so you know put them
over here
you think every cool bit every wrote
their names all these nice and so well
yeah so we'll find out the answer to
that around the end of the video on the
end of the video so guys start guessing
if you use Wikipedia I know you don't I
don't know what are the stakes to this
oh well that's a great question the one
with the best answer will have the
honors Minh
oh but there is a punishment oh the one
who win will have the honors are saying
the goodbyes and they'll say the
goodbyes for all of us on our big house
they can say whatever they want but
while the loser will have to do
something they're not gonna enjoy which
is okay not only is this the Sowers
candy on the market supposedly but also
we found it in the office just in a box
oh so it's definitely poison no we
didn't throw them away because we can
always use them to kill someone yeah
don't put those on the table just be
staring at it the whole show yes wedding
all right guys yeah I really hope I was
closest yeah spelling the best by the
way something else we're gonna talk
about at the end of the show we are
holding a huge Halloween costume contest
and there are prizes and they are
related to
so you who you can make money from
having a badass costume and send it to
us via Stardust but I'll talk about the
details of how to get involved at the
end of the show also by the way next
week we'll be in costume so we'll join
you that and our and our costumes will
be in this contest as well you lend you
money thank you okay in other news we
want to still catch you up on other
stuff that you need to know about so
we're gonna kind of like run through
these a little bit more quickly and just
kind of the stuff you absolutely need to
know so the rest of the news that you
guys need to know about the name of the
show we're gonna start with a stardust
request actually from BJ camp 2011 nice
we finally have a release date for the
Punisher Netflix show November 17th
I cannot freakin weight is going to be
so dark so brutal Jon Bernthal rocks
this character he rocked it in daredevil
season 2 and to see Karen page back oh
man I cannot wait for this show it's
going to be so binge worthy
I'm excited guys alright contact man we
both like what did he believe I was like
falling into I don't know what he was
saying but I like the way which is a
terrible campus send your kids so yeah
we have a we have a new trailer from
Netflix is the Punisher which finally
stop screwing around from that first
trailer and gave us a release date
November 17th
starwars they're dumping this on you the
same time as Justice League we're gonna
make a choose my guess is that they were
up in the air with like political
climate it's like a little tough cuz of
the Punisher show is a controversial
show cuz he's not a good guy he murders
just everybody and then they're like man
Justice League's coming out can we make
it a middle finger and be conscientious
of conscientious of everything else yes
you can and that's what they do yeah so
we're actually we got a breakdown of
that trailer in the work so make sure to
keep an eye out for that
but speaking of Justice League one super
very interesting miscible detail that
emerged this week of the recent from the
recent Justice League trailer that we
actually missed the first time around we
wanted to share with you how did we miss
it I guess not everything you missed
everything you late the audio files
right right right we initially didn't
see it but at one minute 52 seconds into
the trailer you see a shot of cyborg
screaming as he lists what looks like a
mother box I caught that looks like a
mother box I love it floor patterns the
same but some of you noticed there was
something odd mixed in with the audio
here we couldn't make out initially what
it was but isolating the audio channel
someone on reddit pointed this out you
can hear this mysterious line of
dialogue let's roll the clip we okay so
in case you missed that that is some
male character screaming Barry right as
in Barry Allen the flash but who could
this be what could it mean it doesn't
necessarily have to be cyborg in fact
his mouth doesn't look like it's saying
the word Barry in this so what do you
think
oh okay so who is screaming bear okay so
we we don't know where like where this
audio is from so here's my favorite
version of it love what it would be you
might have a similar idea it's happening
it's an echo in time
trying to get her out of there and I'll
go out there and I'll say it's Barry
himself Oh interesting most people don't
like Batman when you just scream brews
screaming another Barry he's gonna guess
it no you guys know I have it I have a
trivia thing you have to say here I
would say it's like um a mirror version
of what we saw in Batman versus Superman
where Barry's what we think was flashy
yelling and Bruce and that nightmare
wormhole vision and maybe now it's Bruce
yelling at Barry
that was my real guess but on the other
I don't want to do I think I think it's
gonna be Barry's dad I think Barry's dad
cuz there's days of prison and you're
gonna get a real I think you get me
origins for all these characters and
you're gonna get a recreation of like
the mom getting murdered yeah curse
because this is our introduction to it
is I think movie I think we're gonna get
little mini to build a character because
you have to know the character to feel
anything for them actually my second
idea was very very simplified it was
batfleck kind of yelling because it was
up to the flash to create some sort of
time warp to throw the mother box box
into another dimension but it looks like
the flash is failing and obviously he's
in a lot of pain and so he's like oh
it's always starts out if that's really
what it is that's what you're saying
your own yes it's green Joe serves a get
somebody screaming or it's green lantern
yelling yet that's always like I don't
know if you notice believes a Green
Lantern
I hope it's Green Lantern with a concept
of a big megaphone screaming from space
and they're like and that's your and
credits teaser for the next Justice
Michael over
what does it go game yeah next up gaming
mm-hmm oh we got something very special
here it's a pretty big news I don't know
if you guys know this but if this
actually is a request that came in from
T D Pete latte on Stardust let's uh take
a look roll the clip all right so we
finally get excited to see the new towel
for the Han Solo movie and it turns out
to be solo solo really really Disney
really Lucasfilm that's the best you can
do solo well I can definitely say that
I'm underwhelmed by the title and good
job with this film you made me upset
Vader big Star Wars announcement this
week it came from Ron Howard on
Instagram yay we get announcements from
filmmakers on Instagram now who said
that the upcoming Han Solo film is
wrapped production finally which I
thought they actually we're already done
but that the title of the Han Solo movie
will be like we said solo : a Star Wars
story
yeah really quick underwhelming and we
will refer to it as solo because we
didn't call rogue one a Star Wars story
we did called rogue one so it's just
technically was yeah and it's that's
what I have the problem with I know it's
trying to say anthology movie and a Star
Wars story so it's saying it fits a long
way but that's the Skywalker story
basically but what I like people have
come for us going there the Kessel run
Kessel run would've been a great one or
smugglers story I don't think something
to do with that I don't like solar but I
really don't like that the a Star Wars
story has to be the thing I don't know
took me it took me so long to realize I
was like it's just so unnecessary why
don't ya why do I hate this and then I
realized when I was a kid in my local
Blockbuster place alright people they
would have yeah they would have trailers
over and over again yeah and I remember
mm-hmm we're back a dinosaur story and
it's like oh my god it's just so low a
Star Wars story and I'm like you didn't
need to call it a dinosaur story cuz
there's a dinosaur
know it already tweeted that and I
didn't realize why you said that and now
as soon as you brought that rushing back
to me that that's what was the
commercial I totally remember that we're
I hope that Buster's there's a ghost
signal of that damn trailer playing I
think I heard this stupid rumor that
John Malkovich quit acting because he
hates the movie we're back but no I
think it shows you don't trust your
audience like you called it Logan and
we're like oh yeah we know that
Wolverines other and x-men story well I
think George Lucas has preserved
blockbuster the last blockbusters on
Skywalker Ranch right so he probably
just has solo is a type of soft drink in
Australia and it's called solo so you
can slam it down fast and now it's like
what's a movie it's the cup you pour
alcohol into at parties and then you
throw away it's a big what's up next
yeah we'll come back to this bomb show
later we got some more but actually also
coming very soon a couple days some of
you guys might know this more big news
sunday will be the return of The Walking
Dead Season eight maybe major characters
actually dying but it hopefully will
show Rick in the all-out war with negan
hopefully delivering some of the action
that the show has been promising for the
past 16 episodes actually keep an eye
out for a breakdown on the season
premiere we're gonna change the way we
do it to hopefully get them out faster
to you guys it's kind of like the
talking dad be talking talking dead and
next up in in other news now this is
coming out about season 8 as we know the
show is in middle of production and HBO
has been taking the most extreme
measures to make sure that nothing leaks
at all previously on new rockstars best
show
weakly we did discuss the fact that they
were shooting multiple endings of the
show just in case anyone saw set photos
or like snuck a little glimpse and then
to get a lot of money to throw away
right just put their mouth like so the
winner of the throne apparently
according to mr. Jaime Lannister himself
the actors aren't even going to get the
scripts ahead of time so they are going
to be fed the lines through an earpiece
I don't know I think that he is making
fun of the precautions that HBO is
taking but what if this is something
that they are going to do now to keep
everything tight lipped and like Norway
to have leaks because leaks ridiculous
at the moment I don't know that they do
a lot of them the actors do like one
night one actress she tweeted out the
script like and and we and Harrington
did something else I'm sorry I'm
blanking on because I don't know my Game
of Thrones stuff but they they've done
it they're been kind of responsible yeah
so now it's like punishment ha ha season
8 and we're gonna make sure that you
regret everything you did but for this
time being on this show if they are in
fact being fed their lines through an
earpiece what do you think the outcome
will be do you think that it's going to
affect the acting do you think yes yes
yes first of all how will they do
Daenerys is like list of titles right
just like so like like but in general
there's so many like slow speeches that
have been and like Tyrion screwed yeah
yeah as like it's like a long little
speed there's the most lines at all have
you ever seen there was a viral video
from micro the guy who does dirty jobs
and he he's one of the best like
voice-over people out there because he
can like do his voice over a while like
I mean he's just very good at earpiece
work so I mean it give them the training
it's very impressive yeah oh you're Miri
it's not great there's the famous like
Hollywood gas right that Marlon Brando
yeah like he was older when he is older
but even in like The Godfather which he
liked won an Oscar for there's like a
picture of Robert Duvall having taped
his lines to his clothes so that like
Brando could just like look over and you
know but he would try to defend it as
like oh no it like helps me I don't know
he had some yes but an article came out
recently for him I think it's Bill Nighy
who's done such an amazing night nah he
the British guy who actually fingers
it's amazing look out for it he's too
always down he feels it but anyway he's
come out saying he's disgusted at the
Millennials and the young actors coming
to set having not learned any of their
lines at all so it's like what is it do
you think that it's a good idea that
they don't prepare lines is it just like
a new thing that's happening with acting
at the moment and none of the old
buddies are upset at how it's going the
only thing that kind of makes sense is
the the penchant for improv on sets
right now you know that again is
supposedly what didn't gel with Lawrence
Kasdan and in problem set but no I don't
think any true actors is like I don't
need my lines right yeah especially show
like Game of Thrones we're like every
line is over and wise and has some kind
of hidden meaning to it you know you
can't say that's dope well let's move on
to our by-the-numbers segment
my numbers okay so we're talking this
week about the number of times
comic-book superheroes have been have
appeared in a film like which super
arrow character do you guys think has
appeared in the most number of major
studio live-action movies now the
highest number we actually found what's
the number 11 now who do you guys think
it is other and not animated just
live-action and well then there's a
Batman TV show and that got its own
movies the TV shows count George Michael
Michael Jordan tell me how I feel it's a
thing American kids say Ben Affleck in
BBS and then in Suicide Squad and then
you had Adam West and I'm gonna say he's
I'm gonna say Batman yeah Batman is a
correct but I thought it was interesting
that so he had 11 appearances any super
anywhere else including Justice League
in that but coming in after that would
be with nine appearances tied Logan
Wolverine and Charles Xavier professor
are two different people right different
people Wolverine actually has the record
for most number of times as the same
character right because it's technically
one's the same timeline one's a
reallocation right is there something
like to these characters that make them
want to be more adaptable or we're more
interested in seeing them over other
characters like also at the top of the
chart would be I'm a Superman had eight
appearances including Justice League
Ironman at eight Nick Fury Steve Rogers
magneto spider-man and Aunt May because
they made every single move you can ma
what is it about these characters that
make us want to see them over
something really interesting about
Batman specifically is that that's the
character that has survived every
reinvention every I mean like I remember
as a kid watching Batman Beyond and
being like so hooked and now looking
back and realizing what a risk that is
to put a mainstream not Bruce Wayne as
Batman shown on the air and it kind of
like doesn't matter the concept of
Batman I mean he's been he's been
reinvented into arrow right arrow just
is essentially Batman the TV show right
all these these different
interpretations they all like work in
some way and I it's I think that's
unique to Batman because like we do we
talked about spider-man fatigue but god
too much vitamin but we don't really say
that about Batman I think that men had a
longer life as well like Spider Man
usually just tells the same story about
him being in high school Batman as well
one of the longest or the
longest-running comic along with
Superman but Batman doesn't technically
have superpowers he's just a rich guy
who has fun toys and a motivation and
he's got the Joker by the way joke there
like makes yes gallery like keeps
reinventing the story but I think that
it's so much more relatable for a kid to
identify or believe that Batman is a
possibility for them whereas Superman
he's an alien and he's got these extreme
powers and but yeah they could
technically get a billion some people on
this planet have a billion dollars and
I'm super disappointed they're not
Batman already I think the villains is
an interesting point they're like I
think more than anyone right I think
like that if at any point you get bored
with Bruce Wayne or Batman as a carrot I
don't know how you would but if you
could like you always have another
villain who could be compelling in some
way that justifies a sequel or justifies
a new film we can all agree we don't
need to see his parents die again on
screen we've seen it I think I did 12
times from TV Uncle Ben yeah you think
we've seen it more times than we've seen
the character of Batman in movies they
were just like no not cut to an old
couple getting murdered
again that'll be next week's by the
numbers some old people have been
murdered just like chip machine yeah we
do have another Star Wars story so I'm
gonna run this one and it's called pitch
me so we've done pitched me before I
think last week was all about change
changing an 80s weapon into a toy into a
weapon with stranger things but this
time it's all about Star Wars and
because we do have a star war story
a Star Wars story how do you say it a
Star Wars story I know so we've already
had in the Star Wars story sagas a rogue
one and now solo obviously gonna be
making more word is that it could be
obi-wan Kenobi's solo story not called
solo Obi but in that 19 years that takes
place on Tatooine where he's just
permitting out some blue milks or Java
deuces damn aging so much and I won't
know how he got so stressed what made
him so stressed moved in next door yeah
Luke is 9 when the movie starts what
he's going to be the next standalone
anthology movie from Star Wars so I want
you to pitch me what's this movie so
there are guidelines of course because
there's some great ideas out there but
I'm going to ask you to suggest a
spin-off around a character that did not
appear in the original trilogy Skywalker
story if it was original couch a
character from the original trilogy I
would love to see a job of the Hutt kind
of story a Godfather's exactly because
he's literally like a mafia boss that's
been running the underground for what
feels like decades yeah but no no he was
in the original so no you can't give
enemies
oh I got one guy Bing Darth Maul yeah
yeah just him in general he was the most
interesting character that I like met
throughout the prequels and I was so let
down and then it was really cool when
they brought him back on a TV show
spoiler where it turns out but I
actually think that you know they had to
hand fist that a little bit because it
you know a lot of children watch the
animation shows it's kind of like now
he's back he's got spider legs but don't
ask too many questions if they actually
they could they could legitimately do
before it but they could also do after
they could bridge the gap between what
happens but do it cinematically da small
hands down is the legs off is the
character that they regretted killing
the most and imagine how much better
attack of the clones would be if Maul
didn't die and was chasing them
throughout the galaxy cool yeah anyone
else gonna do that
hmm I want to see I want to see
something with droids
I really like the droids as a kid those
were besides I mean that you know
lightsabers every kid loves a lightsaber
right you love the droids you like you
love c-3po you love art - and you love
seeing the other ones you're like one of
the other names you immediately forget
them but you like they're the garbage
can he gets his feet branded and he's
actually he can that's because I don't I
don't know original trilogy and you only
know the names of so many other baby I
mean it could be k2 there's all your say
for a movie I wasn't a big fan of that's
like a big banner rogue there's a lot of
stories about characters that are droids
that are used as spies yeah and that
they actually are playing both sides
there's actually an interesting one in
force awakens down in the in butcher
face
I almost said Moses but I'm asking
artist
yeah and her place there's just like old
droid remember they like halt in that
they've spotted
and Bray mm-hmm the droids there are
spies and there's a whole like like
resistance or anti resistance resistance
that the droids could be interesting to
just get into the hierarchy of that
especially once you see okay to us so
it's basically human beings I can still
have complex emotion and I want to see
them like I mean anakin built a robot
that had like complex thought and
emotions and all this stuff I'm like no
no I want you back a little bit I want
to know like the creation of the droids
and like I want to learn more a little
bit about that see I was a human-cyborg
relations
Detroit six million forms of
communication a child program that like
the desert with trash made that fact in
the comics of Star Wars I believe it's
Vader's run there was the evil version
triple of zero
triple zero and is the art too and then
it's the one he's in a new hope but it's
in behind standing behind c-3po is
essentially look so exactly I see
through yeah pretty cool mine really
quickly would be the story of a circuit
owner because this is Anakin's padawan
that he trained up and it was a
beautiful story that we saw through
Clone Wars if you haven't seen it
definitely worth a watch but check out
the actual viewing order to watch it not
just go through its you do have to look
it up it's very it's super out of order
but it's such an amazing character and
obviously they poured a lot of love and
attention and she moved back she came
back in on rebels spoiler but this
character does so much and is not in the
movies
what's all about not mention not like
they're gonna they're gonna bring her in
somehow it feels like they have to just
because she it's definitely Canon get
such a major character its chief they
have to be in a flashback though right
she'd have to be something I mean I
would like a standalone movie in the
intelligence yeah you know wouldn't be
current it wouldn't
episode you also couldn't do it because
you know we don't have a young Hayden
Christensen anymore that kind of screw
that up
Windu doesn't age you could do it 30
years from now it'd still be just as
great and I think even as a kid I was
kind of like waiting for the shot to cut
outside of my psyche landing on a window
washers Yeah right and he just like
doesn't come back
but this Sam Jackson's the kind of guy
who it's like I want a purple lightsaber
and like that doesn't exist it's like
but I want it to like great basically
his Jedi fighting power and style is
that he absorbed sift energy and like
reflects it back and so it's basically
the blue and the red saber together to
make purple but they have to do a whole
thing he's the only one that can do it
yeah yeah all right so up next this is
something we did not do last time but
I'm excited to just throw it at you a
lot of people are asking us to address a
bunch of things don't need to know and
I'm happy to do it but we don't have a
ton of time so we're gonna do lightning
round
and all the sound effects that we just
heard were so intense yeah so I'm just
gonna fire some kind of on-the-spot
random questions to to you guys all
right you guys ready getting these from
Twitter so I'm just gonna say your name
I'm gonna say the question you're gonna
have like five seconds to answer yes
ready okay Sam yes if you could choose
the next big villain after Thanos who
would it be
Thanks at nifty net King got the conquer
he's time-traveling okay you answered
fast enough that I have to cut you off
mod okay can this interesting this is
from a person Momo if you member Momo I
can the night King revive his whites
after they've been killed can he again
revived that what is dead
may never die so yeah okay cool so it
can happen uh Eric why do you ask people
to follow you on twitter when you never
tweet that maybe keV
you're five seconds I'm too busy making
great break down through yah good Sam
the gifted versus inhumans
gifted by a mile like it's amazing in
humans is you said it a car crash over
eight episodes and that's been the
lightning round yeah
any any things that you guys want us to
cover in the lightning round just make
sure when we tweet at the from that
Rockford's account just throw in your
questions you can aim them at people if
you don't like them
and you want them to distress and sweat
they do not see the lightning around
questions ahead of time no we do not and
let's take a look at what videos we've
got in the pipeline we got some great
videos coming up we got a breakdown of
the brand new Punisher trailer the
second trailer I'm working on it now
it'll be great okay no tweets for me
today what else Oh Monday we have a
Walking Dead Season 8 premiere break
down but we're still gonna get to all
the details that you missed I really do
hope what you said where you were being
really negative earlier and you were
really crappy no I really do agree with
you though that it feels like they'll
catch up to the action of the story
behind because we both read the comics
I'm like there is a lot of action that
is supposed to happen it's just kind of
like did write cold now yeah so but well
they have to split everything in a half
right this is a brand new season right
yeah then you got your flash breakdown
cache episode 3 check it out episodes up
right now so make sure you watch that
give it a like comment yeah right so you
guys have been you know great about it
sticking with these Game of Thrones
rewatch is I'm loving rewatching this
whole idea it's kind of fun and like and
there's all kinds of ways that like I
thought it'd be a struggle to rewatch
because it was like it's kind of a
different show you know like it was a
smaller production the the cast is still
kind of getting to know with the tone of
the
they're children but like man they put a
ton of meaning a lot of is they just
used exactly what George RR Martin's
dialogue was but even the scenes that
like they wrote new for the show have
some of the best writing that it's just
amazing check out the episode to break
down this up and mark addy is awesome
they just play Robert Baratheon his war
stories are just awesome and the
stranger think season 2 comes out at the
end of next week you might be out of
town yes we're gonna we're gonna figure
out how to cover it I have a feeling
that there's gonna be some all-nighters
[Music]
in costume because it's our Halloween
episode yes and with that now let's move
on to our 15-second shout out each one
of us has 15 seconds to kind of mention
or rant about whatever thing they found
interesting this week anything they
loved anything they just want people to
know about Sammy what star
yes everyone needs to drop what they're
doing I mean finish this episode watch
more new rock star stuff and then go to
the movie theater and watch happy
deathday it's amazing it is I think it
is no one it doesn't take itself
seriously it is not scary in the
slightest not even not even a jump-scare
no I'm sorry I giggled I loved it go
watch it okay yeah
Oh at the final the finale of functions
and flagons on my channel geek bomb
starring yours truly and with help from
FEMA right here as well is out and this
one Sam do you remember what happens to
be cleared they drink a lot on that
shown flag of them battle and it was
Dungeons and Dragons drinking game on
geek bomb that's it and you're wrapping
it up see the finale that's it Mike
shout-out is for the show mine hunters
which I love it's on Netflix it's it's
got the guy in it you know it's just a
great procedural show it's about like
the the dawn of studying criminal
psychology in the late 70s it's a David
Fincher is behind it it's beautifully
shot the whole series just looks like
you're going through like crime photos
because like his composition of each
shot is like so unnerving but super
precise and I'm still working my way
through the series there's a weird
called opens to every episode
no one spoil it for me you're gonna
spoil it for me now I was a big mistake
telling the show I'm over 15 so actually
Phillip has some thoughts on hunter that
he posted on Star does something to keep
in mind while you're binge watching mine
hunter is that it's taking place at this
pivot point in American culture where
murder goes from something that is done
for passion or is a crime of unfulfilled
desire or want and it goes to being
motiveless sometimes they don't know why
these people are killing and then you
remember well that's the world we live
in today people are killed all the time
and we can't understand why so when
they're trying to answer those questions
about what went wrong in American
societies brain see if you can apply
some of what they learned to today and
there was I just think it's a way to
look at what they're doing because it's
it feels like a time P a period piece
but really they're talking about the
stuff that we are struggling to figure
out right now too
and then finally my just cool thing that
I wanna yeah this awesome cosplay that I
saw so it's an awesome cosplay I tell
abut and it's David no I think TTT J am
calm you wanna check it out but I was so
impressed when I saw this because that
thing has to be like impossible to
balance on your head and make and she
looks so awesome and this is just an
awesome opportunity to remind you guys
that a costume like this could win our
competition that we're gonna have so to
tell you those details real quick all
you have to do is
in this next week so by next week's need
to know we're going to accept
submissions via Stardust just hit add
new rock stars and you just have to have
a costume but essentially a cosplay from
a movie or a TV show just post it and as
a reaction to that move your TV show and
tag at new rock stars and whoever just
had really like impresses us or charms
us or whatever it is we're gonna pick
three winners top prize is a hundred
dollar gift card for going to go see
movies so definitely submit I'm really
excited to see yourself we've all made
like fun costumes before I have a hot
dog costume right now I keep giving my
costumes away you also have a hot dog so
shout out to Kyle thank you okay you
turned him into it guys all make
costumes as good as this in one week I
actually wanted to go as hello this
Halloween because the cake planned it so
often that I was like I have to do this
but then I didn't realize
well how quickly I could go to Australia
and train a spider of that size to can't
train spiders as quickly as utilized
spiders are not sure they're too big so
we'll all be taking part in our own
little mini costume contest but we won't
get any prizes but speaking of prizes
and punishments oh it's the time for the
trivia answers all right so you guys
remember the question was we found this
and it has the question was who what is
the name of Bruce banners take it off
with mod my answer was if it's Martha I
will end a life and you wrote xx right
that is Bruce banners mother's name all
right Hey look I I'm trying to get as
close as I can so I feel like it'll be
something along the lines of mrs. banner
I might have some of the name you have
some thing to go for creativity and for
me I said because I they love
alliterations I'm with Brenda cuz Betty
is taken by my girlfriend's mom's name
is also Betty that's that's always a
strange thing but okay here's the answer
everybody close your eyes
alright guys with drum roll please
[Music]
Rebecca oh that's all right that guy who
dragged us spit last time and Brenda I
guess it was close yeah baby yeah baby
I'm gonna go with the person who did not
write a first name I'm sorry did your
question say oh yeah I forgot you did
you're trying to you know write in a
first name just as Maude
there is a first name on the card this
is just like you're trying to break this
system you found a loophole yeah this is
no one's legal name again we found these
in the office and we weren't the tenants
just get a good handful pop up and call
us when it kicks in you know that muscle
behind your ears its ambassador oh wait
no different that one that way I guess I
sour it seems I'm looking at it leaked
gross all right as a trivia winner I get
to do this fine
all right all right I'll be nice guys
make sure you follow Maude Garrett on
Twitter YouTube Instagram at Mont Kiara
that's close Phillip milena following
fimo on everything or fimo nose or
Phillip Malina Bay you get it's a it's a
guest everywhere you go he's got three
different ones and then you Erin Fawcett
Eric
oh it's written on the thing went out
last week you gave him so much crap for
like not made not hurting our feelings
and then you just read oh I'll make fun
of myself don't know I can't do that I'm
not secure enough to do that podcast at
Sam basher and also make sure you vote
for my costume next week just need to
make clear that I'm gonna be spending a
lot of time making it and I can't handle
losing I can just feel like you're
drooling over there cuz all the sour
make sure to send us like you saw we got
bands in our show and that could be you
just use the starters app to download is
in the description and whatever you
don't eat is the punishment for next
week's person that they
oh no it's not my call the next week's
trivia question is autosampler
alright well so yeah comment down below
tweet us that new rock stories any
thoughts you have we're still we're
listening to you guys what what sections
you loved what sections you want to see
us cover more what topics wants to
discover more subscribe to new rock
stars for all of our deep dives and the
stuff that you decide to put days in a
show and then have me on the pan you did
bye bye guys love you bye
[Music]